let's do it dj complex it's ready set
radio rocky fresh in the building power
98.3 let's go
in the building i'm ready for whatever
my girl got clash machine trying to hit
alexa i used to want to get the champ
burger while the checkers nice rings on
me while i'm jumping over in the lexus
working on the freestyle hot at every
verse i'm so clean with it i ain't even
got a curse finna buy my girl a purse
i'm sipping on the smart water oh dude
hatin imma give it to a smart daughter
i'm straight chillin chillin like a
villain got my mind on the million finna
stack it to the ceilin straight off the
top the homie never flop i'm the flash
guy ever just wait till i drop they gon
hit and in the album everybody ask about
them mmg be the team all my homies
little dream forever stacking cream you
know what i mean yeah i'm straight
spitting tell em it's forgiven
yo off the top of the head man
hey cause he was like what i can't curse
hey this dude actually rapped off the
top of his head a lot of rappers might
want to take notes
let's do it one more time man it's power
98.3 man it's my first time on the radio
in arizona we gotta turn up ready set
radio rocky fresh in the building man
mmg in here at bootleg cab at rocky
fresh at the ogo at wphx at d'angelo
high lattice
let's do it complex
you got something over there complex
hey
yeah
huh this instrument is crazy
let's go
yeah
look okay see i was in supreme when they
was rocking my skin had vape on my scene
when they was in geno green the flash
player ever forever i keep it clean mmg
be the team all of my homies gleaming
all of these whips is mean i see why
they got hate for me cause i be going
hard and they be bowing out gracefully
you go see what's in these abcs and she
catch atd add a number to my phone then
you know i take her home if people paid
attention eight see i never lean i got a
nice balance i can walk along the beam
and i set the bar high so i'm hoping
they can pull vault they sleeping on me
counting million while they doze off
then i break my bros off yeah my whole
team eating we blowing strong to the
weekend and girls we deep in it's our
season like we on the spice rack every
time they think we fall off we coming
right back it's nothing i'm chilling out
in arizona i got them bad girls you know
that i be chilling owner i pass it to my
homies if i don't even wanna i'm coming
off the top once again i tell them bring
a friend the only thing i know how to do
is rap and spin they call me up i'm
standing out then i got it in i'm coming
off the bench repping for the sad town
all the real players but my tunes when
they ride round i'm still flowing still
going cold like it's snowing my road
goal rolly rocking and they know i'm
rolling i'm out here strolling like they
pans down i'm bowling my chain frozen
everybody know it's soaping i don't know
oh man
that boy can rap wow phoenix he just got
blessed right now he just off the top
man
yeah man